today an extraordinary
but for me personally to be able to
introduce such a distinguished gentleman
as we have today Alejandro Toledo who is
the past president of Peru and he is
also to our to our great pleasure
a Stanford alumnus with two master's
degrees from Stanford and a PhD from the
School of Education
he is also now as past president of Peru
a consulting professor at the Freeman
spogli Institute the Center for
democracy development and the rule of
law being able to attract speakers such
as President Toledo with his background
and his nearly unique accomplishments is
one of the things that make Stanford
Stanford for all of us you know it
there's no exaggerating the the personal
pleasure of introducing president Toledo
I first met him when I was running a
training program in 1968 which was
comprised entirely of MBAs going into
the Peace Corps to serve in Peru and
Colombia and professor tour I say
professor president Toledo at that time
was studying at the University of San
Francisco on a soccer scholarship and we
attracted him to come down and work with
the MBA trainees to teach them how to
play soccer and when he came here he saw
this campus for the first time and he
wanted to study here he's nothing if he
isn't a Salesman and he was able to join
the ph.d program at the School of
Education at that time that was not the
beginning but that was the step along
the way to a career that has been truly
extraordinary President Toledo was born
at 12,000 feet in the Andes a place I
know well from our time in Peru he grew
up in very humble origins he was one of
16 children eight of whom perished at an
early age for lack of sanitation
and public health from that very modest
beginning and through a host of
serendipitous circumstances he wound up
coming to the University of San
Francisco on a soccer scholarship and
then the doctoral program at strand at
Stanford that extraordinary story
continues
he returned to Peru after the PhD here
worked for the World Bank the
inter-american Development Bank and then
unbelievable as it might sound from
those origins he ran for president and
unseated the dictatorial president
Alberto Fujimori who held Peru in an
iron grip until President Toledo was
able to succeed him president toledo
signature priorities have been inclusive
democracy development that attacks the
problems of extreme poverty and
universal education to recognize him he
has received if you can believe this 69
honorary degrees from institutions
around the world he was a speaker at
Stanford in oh three at the commencement
at the commencement of the class of oh
three he did not receive an honorary
degree at that time because Stanford
does not give honorary degrees I don't
know how many of you know that but if
you've been expecting one at some time
in your life that won't happen I but he
did he did grace our institution to be
the commencement speaker at that time
and as he told me just before we got
stored it started it was one of the most
emotional moments in his life to come
back to this campus and do that
so he's going to make a few remarks
about ten or fifteen minutes then I'm
going to have a very brief fireside chat
for about 10 minutes with President
Toledo and then we will take questions
from the audience which I assured him
would be numerous and I and I trust they
will be there's no exaggerating the
pleasure I feel in welcoming president
Toledo to this lectern
at the Graduate School of Business today
very extensive very much
George mr. Dean from the bottom of my
heart thank you very much for giving me
the opportunity to share not my pass
another pass through on America but to
dream the future of the region allow me
to pay tribute to this institution that
has shaped my life enormously to be a
shoeshine boy and sell lottery in
newspapers at some time end up to be a
president and then to be in front of
this audience it's a great privilege
that is why I continued saying that my
life is with the result of Anna
statistical error and the world of
probabilities there is a margin error 3%
5% if you are generous
this is only to pay my gratitude to
Peace Corp and to Stanford University
thanks to two of them I had the
privilege to conduct the destiny of my
country for five years I'm not a good
judge of the results I urge you to
Google me final note I always had a guy
to Peace Corps volunteers who were
looking for a place where to live in a
shanty town to work on Community
Development with the dream of John
Kennedy then 1963 60 to 65 and find a
nice Jewish guy professor at Stanford
professor Martin paranoid - am i or him
a lot or what I am now I would like to
thank the Center for Global Business
sign the economy
Latin America has been inundated its
libraries by diagnosis of its problems I
would like to look at the region from
here to the year 2050 never before in
the history of Latin America
particularly in the last 200 years the
region had had the opportunity in its
hand to played a major role in the first
world economy in the next 40 years never
before the region has had now and its
own hands the possibility of playing a
crucial role in the first world not only
in the first world economy but in shape
in a world that well grows it has a more
equal human face
let me substantiate my cautious optimism
the region has an incredible amount of
natural resources I don't know whether
that's a bless or curse but if it is a
curse we have it now the opportunity to
converted it into a opportunity
we have oil 10 times as much as the
United States we have gold silver copper
oil gas fish mill forestry and 26
percent of the world's freshwater
today is the moment for the region ATIS
leaders to have the vision and the
courage to make the qualitative jump a
leap forward using these natural
resources to convert the economy into a
knowledge economy that make us less
vulnerable to the fluctuations of the
prices of our commodities in the
international market now the region is
growing at an average of 6 percent
average there are some outliers but on
the average 6 percent the last 10 years
Peru has grown between 8 and 9 percent
we have the money we need the political
will and we need the vision and the
leadership and I'm thinking 2050 maybe I
won't see it but that doesn't prevent me
from thinking about the type of face
social phase that the world should have
for our children's and the children's of
our children's if we decided to invest
and revert in the high rates of early
malnutrition of the kids if we decided
to invest in portable water sanitation
health care in education of quality my
friends education education and
education this is not a theoretical
proposition of someone who got a PhD
from Stanford it's my life I am free now
thanks to education
so here we have an opportunity we have
learned to manage the economy better now
the crisis that was produced into eight
or two or nine by the way was not
produced by Latin America we pay part of
the costs of it but I'm not over here to
blame anyone but with a fiscal income
that we have where the prices of gold
silver oil gas two years ago the owns of
gold was $200 a rich 1900 now it wrapped
a little bit we have the money this is
the time to make the decision and the
jump number one to invest in the minds
of our people number two to diversify
the composition of economic growth not
to depend on the prices of the commodity
in an international market because that
could change let me drop you just one
piece of data I refuse to do a
PowerPoint because they told me I have
15 minutes for each percentage point
that China drops and its economic growth
it has two points and a half adverse
impact in Latin America that is just
give you an ocean or how much we are
dependent now on selling raw material to
China the United States is no longer the
main troy partner of latin america
is China the United States is no longer
the primary investor in Latin America is
Europe England and Spain in the middle
of their financial crisis my point is
this is the time to invest to the minds
of our people to diversify the
composition of economic growth and to
invest in the minds of our people
beginning with the poorest of the
poorest of the poorest I know I'm not
objective about this but I don't ask
excuses to anyone for my lack of
objectivity
now we confront two difficulties and the
middle several others if we don't reduce
the levels of poverty and if we don't
reduce the levels of inequality both of
them could create an justice and
injustice create corruption if we don't
reduce the levels of poverty and
inequality in the region we can truncate
this encouraged levels of economic
growth and we can undermine democracy in
the region because it will emerge social
discontent which is not an adequate
climate to attract capital investment to
the region you would allow me I don't
know anything more coward in the world
than a dollar a euro a Chinese currency
or a real from Brazil they will go there
whether it is political economic social
and legal stability
so although poverty has been reducing in
a considerable way in the last ten years
and it's very encouraging inequality is
still very high and we are one of the
most unequal region in the whole world
Africa is the poorest continent but
Latin American is the more unequal
region of the world and that could be
contra productive to the sustainability
of economic growth and to democracy
you know I just came from losing one
presidential election because Fujimori
did he thin with me but I'm not finished
yet and I'm absolutely convinced that if
we continue with those levels of
economic growth that we invest in the
minds of our people that we diversify
the composition of economic growth and
to agro industry manufacturing eco
tourism microcredit we can be less
vulnerable and then we can take our
economy in our own hands in the pen less
of China I know the United States is
very concerned this attention is
absorbed by Afghanistan North Korea
China Iraq that's fine don't worry about
Latin America leave us leave us alone we
won't blame you for anything we will
have to do our own job there are however
other challenges to meet that gold of
2050 the numbers and the economy are low
and that's very encouraging
and the social area we aren't read and
that's where we need to invest we are
blue and the numbers incredibly we came
out out of the two or a two or nine
financial crisis much faster than Europe
and the United States with all due
respect but we cannot take everything
for granted we know we need to invest in
the minds of our people to make those
numbers also in blue third we need to
build a strong institutional
architecture with strong institutions
that are accountable to their citizens
where justice is not bought
accountability political economic social
legal stability the rule of law in order
to assure continuity of economic growth
both we need to attract capital
investment I travel the world and I see
a hunger to invest in Latin America
but we need to grow thinking about the
type of life of our children's and the
children of our children's that is we
need to be social and environmental ly
responsible while we do investment and
growth because we are now growing just
for us for today the world is much
bigger that our time life we need to
look more to learn America we have a lot
of complementarities we cannot any
longer blame the United States and it's
fine if the United States and Washington
are concerns for the rest of the world
we will do our job we need to assume our
own responsibility we have a lot of
complementarities we provided some
aggregate value to our production we'll
do it better
we need to deepen in democracy in the
region I mention about the outliers and
I want to be clear I was referring to
Venezuela I was referring to Nicaragua I
was referring to Bolivia I was referring
to Ecuador and I was referring to
Argentina when we clear but on the
average the continent is if one of the
most promising continent in the world
today now we have all the challenges
narco trafficking and citizen insecurity
narco trafficking is no longer only a
monopoly of Mexico it has gone through
Central America
he has gone to South America he got to
Brazil and of course there is a toll
a big toll to pay for those narco
trafficking in Venezuela if we don't
have a strong democratic institutions
corruption makes the poor poorest and
the cost of production much higher if we
don't invest in the minds of our people
social conflict will emerge two days ago
the United Nations has put up a report
about the increase in social conflict in
the region and most of the social
conflicts are concentrated in the
extractive industries moreover let me
tell you my friends indigenous
population 50 million out of 600 million
in the region is become everyday more
aware about their rights they also want
to be part of the benefit of economic
growth of strucked in the gold silver
the oil the gas thank God there is today
the technology to do responsible
investment in destructive industry while
we do the transition to do investment
being socially responsible finally
Latin America is a continent with a
enormous cultural diversity you have an
Indian here we have Japanese also we
have a Spanish we have Germans verb
Chinese that's what it is
but that cultural diversity is our
strength it's not our witness and the
indigenous population is part of our
strength the continent has tradition it
has high roots the Inca Empire the pre
Incas I'm very proud of my origin we
have a route we need to construct a
cohesive society based on our cultural
diversity finally my friends if we
invest in the minds of our people and we
invest in science and technology we can
navigate to 2050 with an optimism
overshare global society
we're students at the university are not
learn only how to calculate you rate or
return to your investment but also comes
with a sole that are much more
solidarity with the rest of the world if
science at the universities come up with
a turnip sources to energy then the
countries that today produce oil will
have to drink the oil the world at one
of ours and we have the responsibility
to live to our children's a better place
this is not a competition this is how do
we can coexist Latin American has 26% of
the drinking water in the world Latin
America has one of the few lands that
the world can still breathe we share the
Amazons with Brazil with Colombia and
Peru I want to conclude by saying my
friends this could be its can sound a
very optimistic scenario the know this
is the time this is the time this is not
a dream of someone who has been
president who'd lost an election but
have not lost its democratic values and
I have not lost my dream for the future
I hope that the students of the Graduate
School of Business at Stanford will
manage the world economy with a the
sensitivity of share society where we
share prosperity
let me finish by saying the way to
return to the investment in poverty
reduction and inequality reduction from
the
intrapreneurship standpoint of view the
way to return is very high 2.4 billion
people I live in today with less than $2
a day and the world 1 billion people are
living with less than $1 a day
2.4 billion can you imagine what a huge
market you will have what do you produce
milk water food you Google Yahoo you can
you can buy it it's a wasted market it's
a huge market if you let them introduce
into the production process that will
have an income and they will consume I
know I have gone over 15 minutes but I
want to thank you from the bottom of my
heart for this opportunity to share with
you my views
my passion and let me tell you I have
not finished yet not in Peru not in
Latin America god bless Stanford thank
you very much
Thank You alejandro especially for that
optimistic outlook about latin america i
wanted to ask you a question that was on
my mind as has been on my mind
particularly in the in the recent
election in the united states if you had
one or two or three words of advice for
president obama about how he could be
the most a lightened enlightened
president that this country has had for
a long time in his dealings with latin
america in his dealings with peru how
the United States can fulfill its role
as a good neighbor to Peru what would
those words of advice be that would be
very pretentious from my part but let me
number one I think that we need to
recognize that we have grown I have it
the continent has we are now and the
capacity to do our own job we have
incredible affinity we're partners
we're so close that I understand the
president obama is so absorbed with
north korea with china with Afghanistan
where Iran with Middle East maybe if my
scenario makes any sense we might have
to redefine the items of the agenda of
the relationship between the United
States improved and the United States
and Latin America technology transfer
technology transfer
maybe we should not concentrate so much
into drugs which is a crucial issue it's
something that we need to make a
decision ourselves if you come mr.
president to Latin America you will
receive with our arms wide open but let
us do our own job will help us a lot you
know increase in the number of land
Americans students come into the United
States will be one important thing we
have last night I was looking at the
numbers 48 million Latin Americans
highly trained that are in a diaspora
and the world if we are intelligent
enough we can recapture those those
Minds combined with the natural
resources and directed to aggregate
values sectors of production we can do
it I think this country is going to be
is going to recuperate well I think one
thing is is is clear in that Latin
America is getting more and more
attention from the US and and rightly so
and and we hope it fulfills that
optimistic scenario that that you
suggest let me ask a second question
having to do with the subject that is so
near to you and and such a priority
which is the subject of extreme poverty
and income equality quality which is
extreme poverty zzyx pression in society
how do you you mentioned education and
education clearly is
solution to extreme poverty but it's a
it's a long-term solution now are an
intermediate term solution are there any
shorter term solutions to extreme
poverty that government can can use I
think the decision of today's leadership
to make yesterday the decision to invest
in the minds of our people again
portable water sanitation infrastructure
health care educational quality I know
it takes time president Chavez and I
agree the poverty is a problem where we
disagree is that he gave his fish away
and that pulls a lot of Club and a lot
of popularity for an election I'm not
working for the necessary let I'm
working for the next generation George
in that takes time education takes time
how long it has taken the United States
there are some evidence that you and I
not Japan after 1946 after the world
I'm nothing person McCarthy gave him a
great favor to Japan they said you
cannot spend more than 2% of the GDP and
military well they invested in health
care in education now so it's a new
power technological power South Korea
1960 there were cheap labor for Japan
now they're industrialized country as
well it's a tiny country
and surrounded or not very good of
friendly people they don't have any
water this is more pieces of water
around or out of the Jordan River and
they became a power a world power in the
agro industry now they're lifted their
prison ships what do they have that we
don't have so what I'm saying
there are evidence there there is no
short-term fix
there certainly are examples of
countries that have have have achieved
the sorts of things you're talking about
and to watch Peru be able to do that or
or Colombia Brazil is is on the march as
we all know would certainly be
magnificent and I know Europe you you
want to be an architect of some of these
things when you say you're not finished
I know that's true I don't want to take
all the time we we are running just a
little bit behind and we're committed to
a journey at one o'clock I would invite
anybody who has a question here we have
a diverse audience from both the
business school and the undergraduate
school and maybe some other graduate
departments are there are there people
in the audience who would like to ask
president Toledo question yes now I if
you will really speak up I think we're a
small enough audience that you don't
need to go to the microphone let me take
right here can you speak loudly stand up
yes
startup culture and now he wants to
study at Berkeley
how will you incentivize him to stay I
should point out while he's gathering
his thought that Peru has a Business
School now called Ehsan which was
founded by the Stanford Graduate School
of Business in cooperation with the
founders in Peru in 1966 or 60 in 1962
that's right in the spring of 62 it's
going to celebrate its 50th reunion this
summer garth saloner and i are going to
be there representing stanford and if he
doesn't come to the United States I
think he ought to go to a son but go
ahead yeah no I think knowledge
technology does not have a nationality
just as much as the defense of human
rights does not have a skin color if you
wants to come to study at Berkeley 202
Stanford I'm not going to get into it
Stanford or Berkeley thing because how
my daughter there by the way Israel it
is very important that the government
the leaders make explicit decision to
create attractive stimulus to recuperate
this 48 million Latin Americans were
highly qualified who are at the OECD's
and Europe the World Bank our Harvard at
Stanford let me tell you several of the
wall street's workers Peruvians land
Americans are going back to Peru
George and I know a bank Banco de
crédito the father has studied over here
the son has studied over here he is no
longer taking his money to Miami and he
is paying for the middle mill workers
managers a middle-level $25,000 so there
is a lot of people from Wall Street's
who are returning to glamour if the
leaders create a special stimulus
scientific cities to return to brew with
the natural resources that we have
combined with the human capital there is
no way to lose it is true Joel that is
not short-term flex we can now make the
decision that those who already out have
been there for 20 years in Europe over
here in return now you don't have to go
back to Peru because many of them or to
learn America many of them already have
sit in their kids and wives over here I
can understand that but you can go for
two months and you can do research
together on two months over there 12
months over here technology may give you
one example Costa Rica until 15 years
ago 68 percent of this foreign exchange
came from the export of cafe coffee
today
you divide the GDP of Costa Rica with
and without chips Intel is in Costa Rica
an hour most of the income that Costa
Rica gets get zero to sell in producing
hardware and software chips it doesn't
have to depend from the changes of the
prices of the market in the internet and
I think you have noticed that there is
increasing opportunity for students who
graduate from American universities if
they choose not to study in Peru which
has a very very good places to study are
getting nearly American sorts of wages
these Dells absolutely which is which is
a huge change from 50 years ago and 20
years ago and even ten years ago and
that makes a difference in a market
economy it's partly about the wages next
question yes over there there there is a
lot of political divisiveness Latin
America that has a lot to do with the
government's having different ideologies
you mentioned in your speech you exclude
a few countries from some of your
comments so my idea my question to you
would be how can we resist 8 the idea of
a Latin American integration and alladhi
that has nothing to do with which
government is in power in particular
countries but which the conditions of
the countries that make like a better
option to face the word to get us as a
whole region and not as individual
countries I forgot to to mention that I
thought it was obvious Peru it's my
fault an American is not an almost
unions continent a Mexico you have
Brazil you have Chile you have proved
you have Ecuador you have Costa Rica
what he's saying is there's no country
quite as nice as Peru
which I'd have to agree with you invited
by the way yeah oh it is true there is
not a animal genius continent they will
remind you the European Union they are
more heterogenic they have wars they are
different religions we have a lot of
things in common
I understand poor to null and the
Brazilians they understand Espanola we
produce a lot of products that if we
provided some market value we can
jointly go out in the market and place
it but I understand your question is how
do you provide continuity to estate
policies because there is true that you
see sometimes every time that our
president is inaugurated he is inventing
again the country we need estate
policies and that's what I was talking
about there was one issue that I forgot
to mention and that is something that
you do in this school and the Graduate
School of Business and add Stanford it
is not enough to have the political will
it's not enough to share state policies
that goes beyond one government I was
two weeks ago with the president of the
World Bank in Washington and we agree
that we need to build the state capacity
to deliver concrete in measurable
results so that people feel the benefits
of economic growth in their pockets and
they don't become disappointed
in social conflict
use the environment for a tractor
capital investment not better
everyone's winning the capacity to
deliver concrete in measurable results
because we can politicians could have a
good intentions and they want to be
reelected but if we are not able to
deliver the results then you're going to
find pockets of poverty the inequality
would create social conflict which is
not a good atmosphere to attract capital
investment and not only that but could
undermine democracy you know in
deference to the hour and we want to be
on time and and adjourn at one o'clock I
think we have time for one more question
where would it be
yes this yeah this is someone from Peru
I wanted to ask what you saw as the
biggest problem in the current education
systems in Latin America and then what
can be done to fix those problems which
education system well you could address
it specifically to Peru or in general
but you touch you touch my heart the
question is the biggest problem in the
educational system in Latin America and
I guess you could say is that access is
that inadequate supply of teachers is it
inadequate supply of buildings is it
priority what is it
while are your education quality of
education you know as a president I
doubled the salaries of the teachers
they were earning $150 a month I double
the salary but I didn't get much in
terms of equality
the words for lo that we need to invest
more in teacher training the quality of
education access to schooling is not a
problem almost 99% of the people go to
school the difference is the quality of
the school and then how do you measure
the quality of a school oh now that is
there Sanders and the OECD has a a test
that enables you to measure the quality
of the education of the students but but
what I'm saying is the quality of
education of students is associated with
the quality of the teachers we need to
invest more and train and better the
teachers particularly in the rural areas
I want to create some houses close to
the schools in the rural areas so the
teacher doesn't have to work walk 18
hours together or have only three days a
week teaching my answer is quality of
education quality of education and that
means teacher training and we need to
redefine the methodology to improve the
quality of the teachers there is no
other way of course good schools one
bill that schools are like the Graduate
School of Business and Stanford well
rudimentary school where the good
teachers will pay well-trained
elementary secondary education in best
then science and technology pay them
well pay them well I want to conclude
George
what I said over there my rule is
education education quality of education
in science in the technology I know
there's a lot of questions and I wish I
could I could have the privilege to to
answer better I had to respect the rules
so the other game and so thank you very
much the meme mr. Dean you have been
very generous by receiving me I'm seeing
that Stanford's transform and itself
tremendously with new buildings I'm glad
to see that a Peace Corps volunteer who
lived in my own State is part of has his
heart and the Peace Corps and all over
here once again I hope we will have
another opportunity to meet each other I
know that you organize students to go to
Peru into different countries and if not
if you are in Peru it would be my
privilege to receive you and the
meetings that you have when they go
organized by bio Stamper and once again
thank you very much for this great
privilege
you